hello this is part b
of the proof complexity part of the
satisfyability boot camp
uh in this talk we'll talk about proofs
of the propositional divisional
principle
especially upper and lower bounds for
the propositional official principle
proof's
first an extended phraga system then in
the phraga system
and then finally in resolution
so let's start with the definition of
the propositional visual principle
so we're going to express the pigeon
principle as a propositional tautology
of course the pigeon principle is one of
these sort of obviously quote unquote
true
statements that says that you can't map
n plus one
items injectively into a set of size n
uh or picturesquely stated as there's no
one to one mapping from
n plus one pigeons into n holes
to make this formal we're going to
introduce variables x i j
which have the meaning that the ith
pigeon is mapped to the
jth hole well let's square brackets
n denote the first and non-negative
integers 0 through n minus 1
subscripts i and j will range over
the sets n plus 1 and the sets n so we
think of i
is ranging over pigeons and j is ranging
over holes
and the pigeonal principle is going to
be a propositional formula
for each value of n we have a separate
propositional formula
and it'll be a valid formula which says
that it's not possible to map
n plus one pigeons injectively into n
holes this formula we denoted p h p
superscript n plus one subscript n
it has two components involving totality
and injectivity
so again we're fixing n we're gonna let
i
range over fixed values from zero up
through
n and uh taught in
i will say that there is that's the
the that pigeon i is mapped to some
whole number j
which will be expressed as the
disjunction over j
of x i j so we can think of that as
expressing
for this i there's some j such that x i
j holds but the for sum
is written out as a disjunction the
injectivity condition
says that for j a fixed hole
in j says that's not the case that
there's
more than one pigeon mapping to j
and this is done by taking the
conjunction over distinct values
i1 and i2 for pigeons that it's not
the case that both xi1j
and xi2j is not the case that both
pigeon i1
and pigeon i2 are mapped to j
and then the pigeonal principle
tautology
says that's not the case that the
totality statements hold for
all the totality for all pigeons i
and that the injectivity statements hold
for all
holes j so let's let's look at this
first of all by examination
this formula p h p n plus 1 n has
size cubic in n it's cubic
because the injectivity statements have
quadratic size because
there's two variables i1 and i2 that are
ranging
overall pairs of distinct values and
then we're taking the conjunction over
all j so the totality
this makes the whole formula cubic in
size and it's saying that it's
not the case that the conjunction of
tally statements hold and the
conjunction the injectivity statements
hold the totality statements are
disjunctions
the injectivity statements are
conjunctions of
disjunctions once you've pushed the
negation signs
into the literals and so if you rewrite
the pigeon principle by pushing the knot
sign
past the ands and pass the oars down to
the leaves of the formula
then the pigeon principle becomes a
disjunctive normal form formula
a dnf and it's clearly a tautology
because it's saying that
the pigeon principle holds
and cook and recall showed
uh that the official principle with n
plus one
pigeon stent holes has polynomial size
extended fragrance so i'd like to start
by sketching this proof
so here's a sort of intuitive high level
view of how their proof goes
uh we've got a function f
mapping n plus one to n we think about
mapping pigeons to holes
with variables x i j indicating that f
of i equals j
the pigeon principle says that f's not
both total and injective
and we're going to do the normal we're
going to assume the piston principle
fails and then get a contradiction is
the way to think of the proof
and to do this we're going to use
induction by n or maybe
in in infinite descent by m we
assume the idea is we assume that we
have a failure of the pigeon principle
mapping n plus one pigeon stand holes
and then we
produce a failure of pigeon principle
mapping one
fewer pigeon to one fewer holes mapping
n pigeons to n minus one holes
and then we repeat this process each
time getting
a new instance of the pigeon principle
that's
false with one fewer pigeon one fewer
hole in each iteration
so for this we're going to identify
variables
x superscript nij with xij
these are um supposedly by hypot these
are by hypothesis
giving one one mapping from n plus one
to n we're going to introduce using
extension
new variables x superscript l i j
for l equals n minus one down to two
and the idea will be that the variables
x superscript l
are describing a failure of the visual
principle
for l plus one pigeons and l holes
and so the way this works is as follows
i
look at the figure on the right here
here i've got
a bipartite directed graph the left
column of vertices
there's n plus one of them are the
pigeons the right column of vertices
there's n of them
are the holes and the solid black arrows
indicate mappings of pigeons to holes
and we're assuming this is an injective
total mapping
for the sake of a contradiction of
course and then
here we'd like to say under the
assumption that this is a failure of the
pigeon principle we'd like to discard
one pigeon and one whole
and get a new failure the visual
principle on a smaller graph
and so for this uh let's consider when
would the variable i
map to the variable j after we've
discarded one pigeon one whole
well the problem might be that
i pigeon i might map to
whole number n minus one that's the
discarded hole
but in this case pigeon number n
was also discarded and it mapped to some
whole number j
and j had to be different than n minus 1
by the injectivity of
hypothesis and so we then just
after discarding pigeon n and whole n
minus 1
we then map i to j and this
works in general for each value of l
from
l ranging from n down to two
or down to three and so this formula
here to the side
then describes how to define the
x superscript l minus 1 i j in terms of
the x superscript l's
namely either in the the next
iteration x superscript l minus one i j
holds if x superscript l i j hold if i
was already mapped to j
or it holds if i was mapped to the just
discarded hole
and the just discarded pigeon was mapped
to j
and then we write p h p l plus 1 l
now using the variables x superscript l
and it's straightforward to show that if
you have
a failure if the formula not p h p l
plus 1
l of the variables x l is false
then the formula well if not p h p l
plus 1
l of x l holds then not p h p l l minus
1 of
x l minus 1 holds in other words a
failed pigeon principle
on l plus 1 pigeons and l holes leads to
a failed pigeon principle
on l pigeons and l minus one holes and
we just
proved this by brute force for
each value of l and then we just put
these together with cuts
to say that um we get a failure of
the pigeon principle from two pigeons to
one whole using the variables x
superscript
one and
however it's easy to prove the pixel
principle from two pigeons to one whole
it's a
valid formula which is finite of
constant size
so putting this all together we end up
with a proof
of the pigeonal statement php n plus 1
m of x and
if you analyze this proof you see that
everywhere
in the proof the the formulas all had
a small size polynomial size the
number of steps is polynomial of each
iteration as well this can be
checked straightforwardly i'm not going
to try to write any of that out for you
but it's straightforward to check that
and what this then does is it gives the
proof
of
cook and recall's theorem that the
pigeon principle has pollinal size
extended fragrance proofs
now what if we tried to convert these
extended figure proofs
the fraga proofs it was a crucial
crucial feature of these extent of
breaker proofs that they used the
extension rule
because if you go back and look at the
extension rule
the variable x superscript l minus 1 i j
was defined from a formula using three
variables x superscript
l and this process was iterated from l
starting
at n minus one down to
l equals three i guess and so
there's essentially n iterations going
on there
and so the size of the formulas triples
if you if you were to unwind these
definitions to try to remove the
extension
the size of formulas would triple at
each iteration
so to say that again if you're trying to
turn the extended fragra proof into a
fragra proof
one way to do it would be to unwind the
definitions
of the variables x super script l
i j introduced by extension into just
the formulas that they
abbreviate the problem is that that
would then give us
exponentially large formulas and thus
exponentially large
fragra proof so the question
is then and cooking recommend asked this
does
extended failure proofs or does the
extended fragrant proof system
provide an exponential speed up over the
fragra proof system
as in are there examples of tautologies
that have short polynomial size
in the extended fragrance system but
require exponential size
for egg approves and they actually ask
then does the pigeon principle do this
in fact
so for that's well the first question is
still open
but the second question is now known
that no the pigeon principle doesn't do
this
i was able to show some years later that
the pigeon principle also has
polynomial size for eager proofs i'll
give a very quick sketch of that proof
on the next slide
but first i want to mention that even
more recently i was able to give a
different proof
of the pigeon principle giving
quasi-polynomial size foreign proofs
now quasi-polynomial means 2 to the
log n to the o of 1 and that's bigger
than polynomial size which is n to the o
of 1.
so the second theorem on the face of
it's worse than the first theorem but
the point is that the
s the theorem about quasi-polynomial
size figure proofs
it's based on the same proof that cook
and recall gave
back in 1979 so let me sketch these two
proofs
so least at a very high level so
first for the polynomial size fragrance
proofs of the pigeon principle
this will prove to be based on counting
so unlike the
quick recount proof which is based on
induction on n
this proof really goes more directly on
the
intuition that the reason you can't map
n plus one pigeons injectally
and holes is that there's more pigeons
than holes
right but to talk about having more
pigeons and holes we need to be able to
compare numbers and in a robust way
and so one way to do this is using
polynomial size
formulas for vector addition so these
are propositional formulas that take as
input
variables describing m integers
specifically
m times m m times n
propositional variables describing the n
bits of m integers
and then the formulas the polymer size
formulas
describe the bits of the summation of
the m
integers and there's several ways to
define such
formulas but one good way is with carry
save addition
and with some work you can write out
those formulas
in a fairly straightforward fashion in a
way such that
fraga proofs can be used to prove
elementary facts about
sums of vectors of of of integers
and so once you have this you can talk
about counting in a very robust way
and prove properties about counting in a
fragra proof system
so here's the proof sketch a very high
level of fragrance proof
of the pigeon principle we assume
for as hypothesis that the pigeon
principle n plus 1 to n is false
and then we prove successively by sort
of brute force as it were
for each integer i prime going from
1 up to n plus 1 we
we express the number of values j that's
the number of pigeons j
such that x i j holds
for some i less than equal to i prime
and we prove that that fact is that
value is at least i prime in other words
the first i prime many
pigeons or maybe it's i prime plus one
many pigeons
map on to at least that many holes
and then once we reach i prime equals m
we get a contradiction because there's
only n pigeons and we're supposed to
have n bigger than or equal to
n plus one which is false so we derive
the falsehood from the hypothesis that
the visual principle is false so
therefore the visual principle is true
so one thing you'll notice is this proof
uh
is of course more complicated than the
quick recall proof but it's also a
completely different proof
so that left open the question of
how good the pigeon principle was for
separating fragrant from extender
fragrance it doesn't really
separate them but maybe the extended
figure proof
based on induction is something that
can't be formalized
in fraga and that would give some
in at least some indication of a
separation between
frag and extended frag up proof length
however
the other proof i mentioned the
quasi-polynomial size proof
is also possible in phrega system
and it is based directly on the cook
recall strategy
so for this we go back from the to the
quick recall proof and recall we have
these variables
x superscript l i j which talked about
the failure of the pigeon principle
obtained
after discarding all
pigeons greater than or equal to l plus
one and all holes
i'm sorry all pigeons greater than equal
to equal to
l plus one and all holes greater than
equal to l
and so for this we um we get
well just in the picture the picture is
shown here here we again we've got the
pigeons
uh zero through n on the left hand side
the holes
zero through n minus one on the right
hand side and suppose
we've eliminated we wanted to find the
formulas vl
ij and so this is drawn here in the
picture
where we're going to well actually with
v
l minus 1 i j from the vljs
and so but we need to define these
directly
not using any inductive process and so
to define v l minus 1 i j
we think of discarding all the holes
number
l through l n minus one and all the
pigeons numbered l plus one through n
so for this we take the original
bipartite graph shown with the black
edges
and we add in some reverse edges shown
with these
heavy dashed blue lines and we take the
the union of these two things and we're
going to use formulas about
st connectivity about reachability
within this graph
so the pigeon number
i pictured here on the right hand side
of the graph
it will map to whole number j under the
following circumstances
while we follow in the original graph
the outgoing dark edge from i
and see where it lands so if it lands in
j we're done
but it may land in this picture it's
landing at n minus one
in one of the holes that's been
discarded so we follow that edge up to
the hole it's been discarded that's
whole n minus one we then use this back
blue edge
to pigeon n we then go forward
using an original edge from the original
hypothesis
from the original hypothesized failure
of the visual principle
and it goes forward now if it ends at j
we're done but otherwise it may end at
another hole that's discarded
in which case we follow the back edge
again and then
we repeat this process until we end up
at some whole j that hasn't been
discarded
and in this case we say that pigeon i is
mapped to whole j
so what this is doing is we're taking an
explicitly defined graph
and it's not inductively describe
defined is just directly defined
and we're taking a reachability
predicate that says that
i is mapped to j if and only if
following the edges in this explicitly
defined graph
there's a path from i to j with j not
one of the discarded holes
and in this case we then let that
formula expressing
the existence's path be v l minus one
i j so reachability
turns out to be an nc2 property it's a
sort of divide and conquer kind of thing
and c2 means polynomial size circuits
of order log squared depth
so if you expand these circuits of order
log square depth into formulas
they're formulas of two to the order log
squared
size and so they're they're quasi
polynomial size formulas
and then the rest of the proof is just
like in the cook recalf case
we uh prove that successively for l
going from n down to
down to two that the phi
l ijs define a failure of the
pigeon principle that is starting with
hypothesis
that the original variables x
divine failure the visual principle from
n plus one to n so again we've reduced
the failure of the pigeon principle from
n plus one to n
to a failure of the piston principle
from two to one
now using formulas of just
quasi-polynomial size
so this means that even the original
proof method of cook and recall could be
done
as a quasi-polynomial size figure proof
and this might seem like an isolated
example but
actually this has come up over and over
again
so
uh there was a paper
with bonet and potassi from 1994 called
are there hard examples for fraga
which examined candidate tautologies for
separating
fraga proofs and extended fragrance
proofs in length so the goal was to find
examples of candidates of tautologies
which were known to have
polynomial size extended figure proofs
and would be suspected to have
exponential length or expected to
require exponential length
fragra proofs so again known to have qua
polynomial size extended fragrance
proofs
and suspected to require exponential
size fraga proofs
and very few were found and the the ones
that were
basically all succumbed to this
quasi-polynomial
uh upper bounds and fraga a prominent
one example found there was
cook's theorem that if you have two
square
of boolean matrices a and b both of the
same size
if a times b is the identity over
over f2 then b times a is the identity
over f2 a number of other
theorems of this type odd town theorem
and so on as well
these are all known to have
quasi-polynomial size figure proofs
which are based on the fact that matrix
determinant properties can be
expressed with nc2 formulas
and this has been carried out in full
detail by rubric samurat
in 2015 and a more refined version of
this result in samurai cook in 2021
another example was frankel's theorem
which was recently shown to have
quasi-polynomial size fragrance
and other principles as well on local
improvement
have had similar results
so although there's a few nagging
examples left open
we just lack good examples of
tautologies
that separate or that are suspected to
separate fraga from
extended fraga with by an exponential
amount
i should add that doesn't mean we don't
conjecture
a quasi-polynomial simulation of
extended fragment by fraga but it's
still
an intriguing idea
so now we turn to what ends up being a
weaker system of resolution so
for resolution we can get
exponential or bounds for proofs of the
fission principle
and this result that goes back to arm
and hawking in 1986
since then there's been quite a few
papers on this
subject uh culminating in some of the
stronger results
obtained a date of of ras in 2002
and raspberry in 2003 and also
successive papers since then as well
sharpening their results
so here recall that extended resolution
is the same as extended phraga
so by the cook raccal theorem
extended resolution has
short proofs the fissional principle but
the theorem of
hawken and everyone else is that it
requires exponential
size resolution proofs so here the
pigeon principle was a
dnf tautology which means if you convert
it into an unsatisfiable set of clauses
the size doesn't change
and these this unsatisfiable set of
clauses expressing the negation of the
pendulum principle
requires exponential length resolution
refutations
of size 2 to the n to the epsilon for a
suitable epsilon
in fact this works even for m much much
bigger than
n where phpm means
m pigeons are mapped injectively into n
as a side remark that i don't want to
really get into there's
in some rather deep results similar
lower bounds can be proved for constant
depth fragra proofs
constant depth fragra proofs means
fragra proofs in which the formulas
are constant depth meaning that the when
you write the formulas with the
negations pushed down to the leaves of
the formulas to the atoms of the
formulas
the number of alternations of ands and
ors
along any path in the formula tree is
is the equal to the depth so constant
depth figure proofs
are a restricted subsystem of
fragra proofs and for each depth of d we
get a
different subsystem and uh this theorem
of beam and pogliazzo cryocheck
potassium pudlock and woods
from 1992 showed that if you fix the
depth
of figure proofs that the proofs of the
pigeon principle
n plus 1 to n require size 2 to the n to
the epsilon
where epsilon is a function of d
so that's the end of that slider mark
let me go back to resolution and i just
want to
give a few comments about what goes into
this lower bound the proofs are all
pretty difficult but
one proof i want to mention is one as
formulated by bensasson
and bigterson which is based on
resolution length and resolution with
so if we have a unsatisfiable set of
clauses
call it gamma the it has a resolution
refutation of course because it's
unsatisfiable
and res land of gamma is the minimum
number of steps the minimum number of
resolution
inferences in a resolution refutation of
gamma
and resolution width of gamma is the
minimum width of a resolution refutation
of gamma
where what we mean by width is that the
maximum number of literals that appear
in any single clause in the refutation
and benzasson benderson
building also on early results of the
edmonds and pagliatso says that if you
have a
k c and f so that k c and f means a c
and f in which
each clause has at most k literals
uh with a total of n variables appearing
in the clauses
are used in the clauses in gamma then
the resolution
length of gamma is greater than or equal
to
2 raised to the power omega of the
resolution width of gamma minus k
squared over n
might pause and look at that formula but
the idea is then
think of k as being a small number and
think of the resolution with
maybe it's some constant times n some
some c times n for some for some
constant value
then then this this is
something like 2 raised to the power
of big omega of n 2 to the raised to the
power some constant times
n a different constant
so we can take linear lower bounds on
resolution width
and get exponential lower bounds on the
resolution
length for small values of k
now this cannot be used directly with
pigeon principle as stated
because the of the hypothesis that we
have
a k c now that each clause has the most
k literals
because the totality clauses are big
they're disjunctions of size
n but we can replace the pigeon
principle with a sparse pigeon principle
a sparse pigeon principle means that
only certain holes are available to each
pigeon to be mapped to so we formalized
this with g
a bipartite graph mapping and
well with uh on the disjoint union of n
plus 1 and
m which we then
the edges in g are then the permissible
places for
the pigeons to be mapped to so the the
g totality and and i says that
we fix an i and we take the disjunction
over the i's
over the j's such that the edge i j is
in g
of the variables x i j and then
what was shown is that for g a constant
degree
graph with suitable expansion properties
that the res
width of the g pigeon principle is
omega of n constant times n for suitable
constant
and then from that we get as a corollary
that the
g pigeon principle and since that's a
generalization of the pigeonal principle
it requires resolution proofs of size
exponential of omega n2 to the omega n
and this gives us the desired
exponential or bounds on
resolution refutations for the clauses
expressing
the negation of the pigeon principle
so that's the end of this talk it's just
a very brief introduction into the types
of lower bounds that can be obtained on
resolution
in part c we'll turn to a different
topic using cdcl
thank you